Selamlar, sevgiler. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. Ben Deniz Hoca. Sevgili
arkadaşlarım, kaldığımız yerden
çalışmalarımıza devam ediyoruz ve şimdi
geldik şiire. Bu videoda şiir nedir?
Özellikleri nelerdir? Bunları böyle kısa
bir şekilde sizlere aktarmış olacağım.
Unutma tüm anlatımı şu kitaptan
yapıyorum. Aynı zamanda sınav soruları
bu kitabın içerisinde mevcut. İncelemek
istersen videonun açıklamalar kısmında
link seni bekliyor. Aynı zamanda bir
tane daha Mavi sınıfı WhatsApp linki
var. Biliyorsunuz şu anda da ekranda
gördüğünüz çok kıymetli öğretmen
arkadaşlarım diğer derslerden de sizlere
yüz aldırmak için çabalıyor. Mutlaka bu
kanala katıl ve diğer dersleri de takip
etmeyi unutma. Öyleyse hazırsan gel
ekran değsin ve dersimiz başlasın
bakalım. Şiir nedir? Öncelikle şöyle bir
tanım yapalım. Seslerin uyumlu
kullanımı, ritimli sözlere ve zengin
imgelere dayanan yani zengin bir anlama
sahip olan edebi metinlere biz şiir
diyoruz. Burada hep dikkat edersen yani
ritimli sözler dedik fakat zengin
imgeler dedik. Zengin bir anlam dedik.
Yani bir şiirin şiir olabilmesi için
normal dilden farklı olması lazım.
Zengin bir anlama, anlatıma ve derinliğe
sahip olması gerekiyor. Bunu
yapabiliyorsan orada bir şiirden
bahsetmek mümkündür. Ama bu yoksa orada
bir şiirden bahsetmek mümkün
olmayacaktır. Bu en önemli hususlardan
bir tanesidir. Ekran tam olarak sığmamış
sığsın. Dolayısıyla ne diyoruz? zengin
bir anlama, zengin bir imge dünyasına
dayanması gerekiyor. Bu tarzı oluşturmuş
metinlere biz şiir diyebiliriz. Tabii ki
şiirler insan duygusuna seslenir. Coşku
uyandırır. Zengin bir düş gücü
barındırır. Şiir türünde ahenk ve
etkileyicilik ön plana çıkar. Yani
etkili olmadan o şiirin şiir olabilmesi
mümkün değil. Etkili olması lazım. Bu en
önemli şeylerden bir tanesidir. Yani
aslında burada karşımıza çıkan kavram da
estetiktir. Estetik kavramı çok çok
önemlidir. Ahenk çoğu zaman olması
gerekiyor. Ama tabii daha sonraki
yıllarda göreceksiniz. E bazı şairler,
bazı topluluklar kardeşim ne ahengi ya,
ne ahengi ya, boşver ahengi de
demişlerdir. Yani farklı farklı fikirler
vardır. Ama genel anlamda tabii ki şiir
dediğimiz zaman ahenkle karşımıza
çıkıyor. Peki ne yapıyormuş? İnsanın
duygusuna sesleniyormuş. Coşku
uyandırıyormuş. Zengin bir düş gücü
barındırıyormuş. Şiirler duygularını
etkileyici bir şekilde dile getiren yani
şiir yazan kişiye biz ne diyoruz? Şair
diyoruz. Yani bu duygularını etkili bir
şekilde ifade edebilen, bu yeteneğe
sahip olan kişiye şair denir. Ama
bununla birlikte şiirde bir de ana duygu
vardır. Bu ana duygu ise tema olarak
karşımıza çıkar. Şimdi neymiş tema?
Şiirdeki ana duyguymuş. Ama bu ana
duygunun sınırlandırılmış, özele
indirgenmiş haline ise biz konu diyoruz.
Yani ne demek istiyorum? Kafanız karıştı
farkındayım. Hemen şöyle Leyla ve Mecnun
hikayesinden bahsetmek istiyorum. Bunu
bir şiir olarak düşünün. Leyla ve Mecnun
değil mi? Çok önemli, çok meşhur bir aş
hikayesidir. Şimdi bu aş hikayesinde
merkezde bir şey var kardeşim. Bunun ana
duygusu ne? Burada hangi duygu verilmek
isteniyor? aşk verilmek isteniyor. İşte
bu aşk bir tema olarak karşımıza çıkar.
Fakat bir de konu vardı. Konuya ne
dedik? Temanın sınırlandırılmış hali.
Şimdi aşka bak. Aşk çok genel bir
kavramdır. Yani neyin aşkı bu? Leyla ile
Mecnunun aşkı mı? Kediyile köpeğin aşkı
mı? Ülkeler arasındaki aşk mı? Takımlar
arasındaki aşk mı? Yani ne arasında
geçen bir aşk? Değil mi? Böyle her şey
olabilir. Dolayısıyla bunu
sınırlandırmak gerekiyor. Bunu biraz
daha özele indirgemek gerekiyor. O zaman
bunu özele indirgersek bu temayı
sınırlandırırsak o zaman ne çıkacaktır
karşımıza? Leyla ve Mecnunun
aşkı onların kavuşamaması
neyi oluşturur? Konuyu oluşturur. Bunu
unutma. İşte konu da budur. Şimdi bir
örnek vermek istiyorum. Burada Orhan
Veli'nin çok ama çok meşhur bir şiiri
var. Anlatamıyorum. Diyor ki, "Ağlasam
sesimi duyar mısınız mısralarımda?
Dokunabilir misiniz gözyaşlarıma
ellerinizde?" şeklinde devam ediyor.
Şimdi buraya baktığımız zaman diyor ki,
"Ağlasam sesimi duyar mısınız?
Dokunabilir misiniz gözyaşlarıma
ellerinizde?" E buradaki tema, ana duygu
nedir? Bir yalnızlık var, değil mi? Yani
ağlasam duyamıyorsunuz, dokunamıyorsunuz
gözyaşlarıma ağlıyorum. Elleriniz bana
değmiyor. O zaman bir yalnızlık var.
İşsel bir yalnızlık olabilir mi? Tema
olabilir. Peki burada bununla birlikte
yani tema aslında duygularını dile
getirirken insanın yalnızlığını ve
anlaşılma çabasını işlemiştir. Tema
budur. Fakat bunu daha da özele
indirgeyelim. Daha da sınırlandıralım.
Mesela diyeceğiz ki şiirin konusu şiir
kişisinin yani burada kimden
bahsediyorsak X kişisi olsun onun
yalnızlık ve çaresizlikten dolayı
duyduğu rahatsızlık ve durumun getirdiği
sorunlar konu olarak karşımıza çıkar.
Bak yalnızlık içsel sıkıntı derken
temaya onu dağa da açtık bir cümle
haline getirdik. Hatta şurada da
dikkatini çekmiştir. Genellikle tema bir
ya da iki kelime olur. Tamam mı? aşk
işte vatan, bağımsızlık, yalnızlık,
içsel yalnızlık gördüğünüz gibi. Fakat
konu öyle değildir. Konu bir cümle
halinde olmalı ki burada da zaten cümle
halinde bunu tanımlamış olduk. Demek ki
tema bu konuda onun sınırlandırılmış,
daha da özele indirgenmiş halidir.
Tamam. Bunu aklımızda tutuyoruz. Şimdi
şiirle ilgili bilmen gereken birkaç
kavrama da değinmek istiyorum. Bunlara
biz ne diyelim? Genel anlamda nazım
birimi diyeceğim. Bu önemli temel bir
konu. Bundan sonra her zaman karşına
çıkacak. Yani bundan sonra 2. dönemde de
çıkacak, 10. sınıfta da çıkacak, 11'de
de, 12'de hep çıkacak. O yüzden şimdi
öğren ki bir daha çalışmak durumunda
kalma. Şimdi nazım birimi demek şiirde
satırların kaçar kaçar kümelenmesi
demek. Yani eğer şu şekilde hoşça bak
zatına ki zübtei alemsin sen. Bak tek
satırdan oluşuyor. Görüyor musun? Bir
satır var. Bir satır var. İşte biz buna
dize ya da mısra diyoruz. Tek bir satıra
tekrar söylüyorum. Mısra ya da dize adı
verilir. Mısra Arapçası, dizesi Türkçe.
Peki hocam iki tane alt alta gelseydi bu
örnekte olduğu gibi mesela Fuzuli'den
beni candan usandırdı cefadan yar
usanmaz mı? Felekler yandı ahımdan.
Muradım şemi yanmaz mı? Şimdi bu ayrı
olacak. Ayrı olacak tabii. Dikkat
ederseniz 1 2 bak 1 2 iki dize alt alta
gelmiş. Bu bütüne ne denir? Bent denir.
Bunu unutma. Peki hocam dör tane alt
alta gelseydi mesela Pir Sultan
Abdal'dan bir örnek var. Derdim çoktur
hangisine yanayım yine tazelendi yürek
yarası. Ben bu derde nereden derman
bulayım? Merşah elinden ola çaresi
şeklinde. Bak 1 2 3 ve 4. Gördüğün gibi
4 tane dize alt alta geldiyse ben buna
dörtlük diyeceğim. Bunu da unutma. He
hocam bir tanesi dize, iki tanesi beyit.
Eğer 4 tane ise biz buna dörtlük
diyoruz. Fakat bazen de böyle olmuyor.
Ne oluyor? Ya 3 oluyor, ya 5 oluyor, ya
6 oluyor. O zaman biz buna ne diyeceğiz?
Biz buna band diyeceğiz. Bunu unutma.
Yani gördüğünüz gibi dize, beyit,
dörtlük ışınlak dizelerin oluşturmuş
olduğu tüm kümelere bent adı verilir.
Ama mesela daha sonraki yıllarda
göreceksiniz divan edebiyatında ikiden
fazlasına genel olarak bent denir.
Kafanızı karıştırmayayım ama sen şöyle
kodla. Bir tane varsa dizede, iki tane
varsa birlikte, 4 tane varsa dörtlükte.
Bunun dışında ise o zaman buna bent.
Mesela Kandilli'de eski bahçelerde akşam
kapanınca perde perde bir hatıra zevki
var kederde. Bak 1 2 3 tane diz alt alta
gelmiş. Yahya Kemal Bey'nın biz buna
bent diyeceğiz. Bunu unutmuyorsun. Şöyle
kalemle seçebilirsem yazacağım. Buna da
bent denir. Peki Türk edebiyatının
hangisi kullanmıştır? Açıkçası birçoğu
kullanmıştır. Yani birçok nazım birimi
kullanmıştır. Mesela İslam devet öncesi
Türk edebiyatında daha İslam deviyeti
kabul etmeden Orta Asya'da ve halk
edebiyatında dörtlük kullanılmıştır.
Unutma yani bizim milli nazım birimiz
dörtlüktür. Bunu unutmayacaksın. Fakat
mesela divan edebiyatı vardır. Bu
İsamiyetten sonra Arap ve İranlılardan
aldığımız bir edebiyattır. Mesela orada
da ikili ikili şiirlerin yazıldığını
görüyoruz. E buna da ne denir? Buna da
beyit adı verilecektir. İşte böyle şiire
genel anlamda bir giriş yapmış olduk.
Aslında temeli sana serdim. Bundan
sonrası daha da derinleyeceğiz. Bundan
sonraki videoda şiir türlerini ele
alacağız. Eğer bu videoyu anladıysan
artık o yeni videoya geçebilirsin. Ben
de veda edebilirim. Bir sonraki derste
tekrar görüşeceğiz. O zamana kadar
kendine çok iyi bakıyorsun. Ama lütfen
bu videoyu beğen, kanalıma abone ol ve
daha da önemlisi düşüncelerin olumlu
olmuşuz fark etmez. Benimle paylaşmayı
unutma. Bunlar benim için son derece
kıymetli. Hoşça kal. Seviliyorsun.